Speaker 1: Donald Trump was soaking wet and
slurring badly in a bizarre funeral promotion.
Now, you might say. David, What? What do you mean?
A funeral promotion? Like an ad for a funeral?
Yes. Things have gotten, I dare say, Kafkaesque
in the aftermath of the tragic passing of Dymond,
of the dynamic pro-Trump duo Diamond and Silk.
You may recall that Diamond recently died,
believed to be from COVID, although I still
don't know if it's been confirmed. This was
a pro-Trump group of group two women pro very,
very much pro-Trump. Spreaders of anti-vaccine
disinformation, spreaders of all sorts of
different misinformation, in fact, I should say.
Donald Trump announced that
he will be presiding over the
funeral of Diamond in North Carolina
over the weekend. He is soaking wet,
almost dripping. He is slurring extraordinarily
badly. But the strangest part of it might be
why are you advertising a funeral? It's an
unusual thing. Look at this. And remember,
folks, this is not a parody. This is real.
Speaker 2: Please join us on Saturday, January.
Speaker 1: Saturday, the.
Speaker 2: 21st in Fayetteville,
North Carolina. She loved that state and so
do I. As we celebrate the life of Diamond,
she lived it in a credible way. And we're going
to have a wonderful celebration and ceremony.
All of diamonds, families and silk. We love
silk. Her sister, she loved her sister so
much and they loved each other and they
really loved the world. They were with me
from the beginning and they never wavered. So
we're going to celebrate. Silk will be there,
but I'll be there. And we're going to celebrate
the life of Diamond. See you in North Carolina.
Speaker 1: Are they going to celebrate? I'm
having. Trump only mentioned it four times. I
guess they're going to celebrate there. Why is he
soaking wet? Why is he slurring? But the wackiest
part of this is he's promoting a funeral in a very
strange way. And maybe that's the silliest part
of this entire thing is, you know, when I think
of people needing comfort, people really needing
someone who knows in difficult times just exactly
what to say to really provide that comfort.
It's hard to think of a worse person to deliver
that than Donald Trump. Truly. And it would not
surprise me if Trump didn't even know which one
was diamond and which was silk. And there are
really maybe the other thing to talk about here
before we move on to clips from the actual eulogy,
which but listen, if you Trump giving a eulogy,
okay, it's going to be absolutely crazy and we
will get to that. There is an irony in a sense
of Trump speaking at the funeral of Diamond, who
was a vocal supporter of Trump's presidency and
his failed campaign and all of it. Given Trump's
endlessly divisive rhetoric and treatment of the
black community, that's at the end of the day,
one of these issues that continues to rear its
ugly head when when you look at a situation like
diamond and silk or blacks for Trump or whatever
the case may be, the ability of and again,
I don't know if it's like seeing past what Trump
actually is and was with regard to many of these
communities or an indifference or a deliberate
ignoring of it for personal gain because Diamond
and Silk got a ton of publicity and became
known as a result of their support of Trump.
I don't know what it is, but that is really
the irony of all of it. And as you can imagine,
Trump as out of place at a black church
during a during a funeral for a black woman,
as you can imagine. And we're
going to talk about that next